vamos a medir algunos líquidos con la
ayuda de recipientes o envases que
puedes encontrar en tu escuela o en tu
casa supongamos que hay una fiesta en la
escuela y que a ti te tocó llevar agua
para todo el grupo cuál de los
siguientes recipientes elegirías para
llevar la mayor cantidad de agua tenemos
una jarra un frasco y un vitroleros en
cuál de ellos cabe más agua cierto en el
beat trolero ya que si lo comparamos con
los otros recipientes es mucho más
grande pero tengo curiosidad por conocer
cuántas jarras se podrían llenar con el
agua del vitroleros si observamos y
comparamos su tamaño podemos calcular
cuántas jarras se podrían llenar
sí sobre ponemos las jarras de esta
manera podemos ver que caben 12
y cuatro jarras completas aunque la
parte de arriba aún queda algo de agua
sin embargo es muy probable que no se
logre llenar una jarra más porque
quedaría muy poquita agua
podemos usar un recipiente más pequeño
como este frasco de aquí porque su
proporción es menor y por lo tanto
almacena menos agua que una jarra listo
logramos llenar cuatro jarras de agua y
un frasco ahora debes repartir el agua
en otros dos recipientes más ya que la
maestra necesita preparar agua de limón
y agua de jamaica cuál de las siguientes
opciones elegirías para llenar más
rápido estos dos recipientes
la mejor opción es la jarra con los
otros dos recipientes tardarían más
tiempo porque son más pequeños y tienen
menor espacio para pasar el agua del
vitroleros a los otros dos recipientes
cuántas jarras de agua necesitamos para
llenar un recipiente utilicemos el mismo
procedimiento y comparemos el recipiente
y las jarras caben dos jarras y también
quede espacio en la parte de arriba no
creo que quepa otra jarra completa así
que vamos a llenar una pero solo hasta
la mitad bien un recipiente se llena con
dos jarras y la mitad de otra más vamos
a calcular con cuántos vasos de agua
podemos llenar esta jarra contemos aquí
cabe 1 2
y cuatro vasos y aunque podemos ver que
sobró algo de espacio en la jarra ya no
es suficiente para un vaso más
necesitamos un recipiente más pequeño
para poderla llenar por completo vamos a
probar con este porque tiene una
proporción menor a la del vaso aquí
caben 1 2 y 3
entonces para llenar está jarra de agua
se necesitan cuatro vasos grandes y tres
pequeños
como puedes ver calcular cuántos
recipientes caben dentro de otro nos
ayuda a crear nuestras propias medidas
sigamos aprendiendo en la fiesta de la
escuela alguien olvidó llevar los vasos
para repartir el agua afortunadamente
uno de tus compañeros se encontró una
caja con varios vasos la situación es
que hay vasos de distintos tamaños
qué se puede hacer para que al repartir
el agua todos sus compañeros tengan la
misma cantidad y ninguno se moleste
porque le dieron menos agua
reflexiona un poco sobre esto
si tienes distintos vasos cómo hacer
para que a todos les sirvan la misma
cantidad de agua sin importar si el vaso
es grande o pequeño
perfecto podemos elegir uno de los vasos
más pequeños y con este servir agua a
todos tus compañeros tomar un vaso como
medida única nos ayudará a que se sirva
la misma cantidad sin importar si un
vaso es de diferente tamaño
ahora sabes cómo podemos calcular cuánto
líquido cabe en un recipiente a partir
de otro para lograrlo tuvimos que tomar
en cuenta el alto largo y ancho de cada
uno de los recipientes con sólo verlos
como no siempre se puede calcular de
esta manera existen recipientes con
medidas exactas que nos ayudan por
ejemplo jarras vasos jeringas e incluso
mamilas y tú que otros instrumentos
conoces para medir un líquido